we have seen the harms of regulatory
capture we know
the kind of money that's at stake in the
pharmaceutical industry we know the kind
of collusion between pharmaceutical
companies uh and government and so that
doesn't mean i mean i always like try to
be careful when i'm thinking or speaking
not to assume that wherever there's a
conflict of interest
the decision will always be made in
favor of the wrong interest
right i don't want to make that
suggestion because you could have a very
benevolent billionaire right who always
makes the you know who who really does
genuinely care for for humanity
but
whenever there's a conflict of interest
like that and we're talking about tens
of billions of dollars in stock that are
now
being dumped by these spidey ceos but
um whenever you're talking about that
kind of money
it's incumbent upon us as the average
citizen as the average drug taker is the
average vaccine recipient to be
skeptical and to ask questions is this
necessary am i really in a state where
i'm facing
a viral threat that has a high infection
fertility rate for my
age group
am i
and then on the other side
what kind of trials have we seen how's
that data looking you know we had the
the data from pfizer released and well
gee it's not looking so good and we just
had i was just reading this morning
about a german um
insurance company that you know they're
saying that
i think 10 million people 10 million
vaccine recipients there's data on them
now and it's it's i think the word from
the ceo is it's shocking and requires
further investigation so
it's it's not surprising to me that this
regulatory capture can happen
what's surprising and concerning and
needs to be addressed moving forward i
think is that the average person has the
critical thinking skills to ask these
questions
and be more reflective
and that physicians
right that who
are
should be responsible for administering
these
or not conveniently right this practice
of vaccinating for covet has been taken
out of the i think fiduciary
relationship between physician and
patient and put in i mean in our case
you can go to like your local sports
arena and get it from who knows who
right
um
[Music]
we need to be more critical we need to
be we we need to
i was talking to
jordan peterson a while he had this
beautiful metaphor about his tool shed
you know he was thinking saying that
that thinking and critical thinking is
like you've got all these tools in the
shed and you need exactly the right tool
for the specific job and you need to
keep them rest free and sharp and ready
to go and know where they are but
thinking is like that you know and this
has been
um this covet test which is not a
biological test by that i mean it's a
test of our
ability to think through
um
a massive onslaught of information
coming at us from a perceived set of
authorities and i think we've failed
miserably it doesn't mean
that failure needs to become
it's not inevitable that we will always
fail
but we need moving forward
to look back historically
um and figure out how we got ourselves
to this place and how we can do better
we were talking earlier about about the
past and about historical events
um like what happened in europe in the
30s and 40s and why we're so reluctant
to make analogies to that that point in
time
um but it seems to me that if we don't
if we close off the possibility of
looking at the past as a possible way of
informing how we move forward we are
disabling ourselves beyond measure
yeah we uh
so i've been focused on
pharma and regulatory capture for many
years because of a project i did in in
graduate school that
revealed a flaw in the drug safety
system which as far as i know is still
not corrected it's a flaw that makes
things look less toxic than they
actually
are but most people although
until a couple years ago
would have had some sense of yes pharma
corruption is a real thing
during covid
completely suspended their disbelief
amnesia yeah and i have
the
sense that we are
we walked into the largest version of a
game that pharma plays
every day
of every week
throughout the year right pharma is
constantly in the process
of trying to define a need for which
they have
a pharmacological solution
trying to expand the definition of that
need so it covers the maximum number of
people
trying to convince doctors that the
solution that they have is in fact the
best one and it is the should be the
standard of care
trying to persuade government that the
solution is safe enough to be worth
the costs
and that what happened
is that kovid opened up the largest
new market sector conceivable
and that this game has been played out
where
i don't know
i'm sure you had the same experience i
did where
somehow pharma was speaking even through
my friends
right pharma is telling me that i was
being irresponsible to discuss what i
was perfectly well qualified to see as a
scientist who trained to understand
complex systems as somebody who has
studied immunobot immunobiology i was
perfectly capable of looking looking at
these vaccines and saying well wait a
minute
there are all kinds of ways this could
go wrong
they haven't been around long enough for
us to know in which of these ways they
will go wrong and i'm being mandated to
take it over what kind of risk
right those were all
and mandated not to talk about it
because we live in this era of this this
credentialism this expertise and then oh
and by the way what we mean by an expert
is only these particular people we've
sort of deemed these people appropriate
mouthpieces or appropriate i wouldn't
even say sort of subjects for debate
because we don't even see debate
happening between you know amongst
themselves we're just seeing
only these people who are considered to
be experts are allowed to speak of these
things
and
you're not an expert if you disagree
not if you don't have the appropriate
credentials or background or education
but what makes you a non-expert is your
disagreement
with the ideology of the system
that's exactly right and it is the most
upsetting thing for anybody who studied
logic in any way
the idea that it is your very
disagreement with the consensus that
renders you unqualified when the point
is well then
what is the nature of this consensus
right if there are those of us who
ordinarily would be considered qualified
and if we were in agreement you'd say we
were qualified but as soon as we
disagree we are not qualified and that
consensus isn't anything it's it's
coercion itself
[Music]